[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und christian sievers
guten abend in ein sie sind die letzten
internationalen presse beobachter die
letzten augen der welt in mario pohl süd
ost ukraine die letzten zeugen von dem
was wochenlanges russisches bombardement
und russische belagerung gemacht haben
mit einer stadt in der x 400.000
menschen ihr zuhause hatten zwei
reporter der nachrichtenagentur ap haben
ausgeharrt in mario pohl weil sie
wollten dass die welt sieht was sie
sagen sie haben den angriff auf
schwangere frauen in einem krankenhaus
dokumentiert und es mit dem mut der
verzweifelten geschafft die bilder
heraus zu senden aus einer von der
außenwelt komplett abgeschnittenen stadt
sie mussten erleben wie der propaganda
apparat des kreml versuchte ihre arbeit
zu diskreditieren
hier ist ihr bericht
fünfzehnter märz ist dies laut schär
norf und jewgeni malkin
die beiden berichten wie schon häufiger
aus dem krankenhaus in mariupol wo
verletzte auf hilfe warten und
traumatisierte mutter auf die behandlung
ihrer kinder
ärzte die verletzte operieren nicht
wissend ob im nächsten augenblick eine
bombe einschlägt plötzlich stürmen
ukrainische soldaten in die klinik sie
müssten mit kompagnon versteht nicht
warum sie fliehen schreibt der
journalist durch die zerstörte stadt und
erst als sie in sicherheit sind kapiert
er die ukraine wollen sie retten damit
die wahrheit über mario pohl ans licht
kommt damit sie nicht in russische hände
fallen und gezwungen werden aus zu sagen
sie würden nichts als fake news
verbreiten
so wie in diesem fall am 9 märz als
chernoff und sein fotograf in der
entbindungsklinik drehen und die russen
danach behaupten die schwangere sie sei
eine schauspielerin in
all den wochen ist es schwierig bilder
in die welt zu schicken zu dokumentieren
was geschieht im mario pohl es gibt
keinen strom nicht für die bevölkerung
und nicht für journalisten aber die
beiden sie schaffen es immer wieder zu
senden überall sollen man sehen dass in
mariupol menschen sterben was die
angriffe anrichten welche zerstörung und
wie menschen herumirren weil sie hab und
gut verloren haben und wie viele
menschen verletzt in die krankenhäuser
gebracht werden in der hoffnung dass sie
überhaupt versorgt werden können jetzt
gibt es diese bilder nicht mehr
die
journalistin sie mussten raus aus der
stadt und sie haben die flucht überlebt
vorbei an 15 russischen checkpoints
jedes mal in angst sie sind jetzt wohl
in sicherheit wo ist nicht bekannt
chernoff ist froh über jede information
jedes bild das sie verbreiten konnten
denn noch nie hatte er das gefühl so
schreibt er heute dass es so wichtig ist
das schweigen zu brechen
petra otto und simon hrubesch haben die
erinnerung der ap reporter
zusammengefasst die zum schluss
schreiben wir waren die letzten
journalisten in mario pohl jetzt gibt es
keine mehr trotz der katastrophalen lage
wird es keine kapitulation geben von
mario pohl sagt die ukraine heute mario
pohl rettet heute sowohl kiew als auch
besser meint der verteidigungsminister
katrin eigendorf ist für uns in odessa
katrin guten abend was meint er denn
damit
nun die hafenstadt mario pohl ist für
die ukraine von ungeheurer strategischer
bedeutung einerseits ist da die größte
stahlindustrie des landes und wir sehen
ja das stahl werks oft wurde auch
getroffen und geht in flammen auf und es
sichert der ukraine den zugang zum
social mehr und das ziel russlands ist
es natürlich langfristig der ukraine den
zugang zu mir zu versperren und von
mario pohl aus wenn man die stadt in
einmal kontrolliert ist man auch relativ
schnell in odessa und das ist die größte
hafenstadt der ukraine und das ist das
problem wenn die ukraine keinen zugang
mehr zu den häfen hat dann ist natürlich
die versorgungslage im land auch sehr
sehr kritisch und warum jetzt mario pohl
auch für die russen so wichtig
mario pohl hat in diesem krieg eine
emotionale bedeutung bekommen wladimir
putin erzeugt dort im prinzip die bilder
mit denen er versucht die bevölkerung
hier der erbittert widerstand leistet zu
demoralisieren sein narrativ davon dass
er die ukraine hier befreien will das
möchte er natürlich durchsetzen und die
bilder die ihr hier zeigt von diesen
enormen katastrophen dieser humanitären
katastrophe menschen die abgeschlossen
sind von wasser die keine medikamente
mehr haben die in kellern verharren
damit versucht er natürlich zu zeigen
ist bereit sehr sehr grausam hier
vorzugehen gegen die zivilbevölkerung
und deswegen hat mario pohl eine
unglaubliche symbolische bedeutung in
diesem krieg karen du wirst odessa den
ort an dem du im moment bis morgen
verlassen mit deinem team mit welchem
gefühl
ich nehme aus diesen wochen die ich hier
verbracht habe das gefühl mit dass ich
mir nicht selber habe vorstellen können
dass wir solch einen krieg noch einmal
in europa erleben diese grausamkeit mit
der putin und die russische armee gegen
zivilbevölkerung
vorgeht wirft uns wirklich
zivilisatorisch würde ich mal sagen um
viele viele jahre zurück ich nehme mal
ein beispiel ich hatte hier vor
eigentlich in odessa in einem waisenhaus
zu drehen der direktor hat mir gesagt
das kann ich leider nicht zulassen weil
wir dürfen hier keine bilder
veröffentlichen denn das riskieren wir
dass dieses waisenhaus vielleicht
angegriffen wird ein waisenhaus in dem
kinder sind als strategisches ziel in
einem krieg das ist in der dimension so
grausam das ist fast schon unfassbar ist
und ich frage mich wirklich wie ein
machthaber wladimir putin der breites in
diesem krieg so grausam gegen die
zivilbevölkerung vorzugehen menschen
auszuhungern kinder anzugreifen der
einen propagandakrieg führt der ja kaum
noch begreifbar ist wie man mit dem
irgendwann zu einer einigung kommen will
das heißt wie sich dieser krieg wirklich
beenden lässt diese große frage nehme
ich einfach mit und ich muss sagen ich
bin selber zur stunde relativ ratlos
katrin eigendorf in odessa vielen dank
im krieg mit der ukraine droht ein
blutiges patt das schreiben
militärstrategen aus den usa und sie
befürchten für wochen oder gar für
monate wenig bewegung aber viele tote
die situation heute beschreibt laura
panik
übrig geblieben sind nur trümmer ein
einkaufszentrum im westen kiews
getroffen von russischem bomben ganz in
der nähe wohnhäuser nun ist der
stadtviertel eine einzige ruine das
russische verteidigungsministerium
spricht von rein militärischen zielen in
der nacht zum 21 dritter wurde durch
eine vernetzung zwar für eine stellung
der ukrainischen raketenwerfer sowie
deren lager in einem bereits
stillgelegten einkaufszentrum vernichtet
nach ukrainischen angaben wurden in der
nacht acht menschen getötet ebenso gibt
es viele schwerverletzte
der bürgermeister ruft seine landsleute
weiter zum durchhalten auf
unsere stadt ist im moment eine einzige
straßensperre wir sind auf jeder straße
im nebengebäude mit vier posten
vorbereitet wir werden unsere stadt
niemals den aggressoren überlassen
von den 44 millionen einwohnern des
landes befinden sich laut
un-flüchtlingshilfswerk
inzwischen zehn millionen auf der flucht
also fast ein viertel der bevölkerung
trotz des beschusses entscheiden sich
aber auch viele in ihre häuser
zurückzukehren oder in das was davon
übrig ist
wir haben angefangen ein bisschen
aufzuräumen aber alles ist komplett
zerstört
bei aller zerstörung für viele ist kiew
nach wie vor ein zufluchtsort
der russische convert kam in unseren ort
und sie haben einfach angefangen zu
schießen ich und meine großmutter wurden
verwundet mir wurde in die hand
geschossen meiner oma ins bein
der ukrainische verteidigungsminister
betont russland werde von alleine nicht
aufhören
das letzte mal dass es in europa diese
zerstörung gab war während des zweiten
weltkrieges moskau hat angst vor unserer
armee deshalb reifte zivilisten an das
ist staatsterrorismus deshalb muss der
kreml gestoppt werden
in brüssel haben heute die außen und
verteidigungsminister darüber beraten
wie und ob putin gestoppt werden kann an
tag 26 des russland krieges gegen die
ukraine unter anderem wurde eine neue
schnelle eu eingreiftruppe beschlossen
ja die eu soll also eine militärische
eingreiftruppe bekommen und deutschland
will das herzstück stellen einen voll
ausgestatteten gefechts verband etwa
1500 bis 2000 soldaten und gerät hatte
deutschland bereits früher in brüssel
angekündigt anne gellinek in brüssel was
soll denn diese neue eingreiftruppe
jetzt genau leisten
diese neue eu eingreiftruppe soll das
ohnmachtsgefühl der europäischen union
mindern das gefühl dass die europäer
beschlichen hat zum beispiel beim
truppenabzug aus afghanistan als sie
feststellten dass ihr den flughafen von
kabul nicht alleine sichern können ohne
die amerikaner und ihre eigenen leute
dort nicht rausholen rausholen können
diese neue eingreiftruppe baut auf einer
vorgänger struktur auf den sogenannten
eu battlegroups die sehr viel geübt
haben aber nie eingesetzt wurden weil
sich die 27 mitgliedstaaten nie darüber
einigen konnten was diese truppe
eigentlich soll die franzosen wollten
sie nach mali schicken die spanier nach
nordafrika und die deutschen am liebsten
gar nicht einsetzen jetzt aber gibt es
durch den krieg in der ukraine ein
gemeinsames gefühl der bedrohung und
deshalb konnten sich die 27 heute darauf
einigen dass man eben eine gemeinsame
truppen
krisenintervention strip gründen will
und andere hast ja gerade die probleme
in der vergangenheit angesprochen wie
stehen denn jetzt die chancen dass diese
militärische seite der eu in zukunft
besser funktioniert als bisher
also die widerstände die bisher gegen
eine gemeinsame europäische verteidigung
da waren die sind natürlich auch trotz
des ukraine kriegs immer noch da der eu
außenbeauftragte josef borel hat heute
in der pressekonferenz nach dem treffen
ein paar interessante zahlen genannt er
hat gesagt alle eu mitgliedstaaten
zusammen 27 geben zusammen 200
milliarden euro im jahr aus für
verteidigung das ist genauso viel wie
das militärbudget der chinesin und
viermal so viel wie die russen ausgeben
für verteidigung heißt also die europäer
scheitern nicht am geld sondern sie
geben es falsch aus sie geben es aus für
die parallele produktion von waffen in
verschiedenen mitgliedstaaten die sich
gegenseitig konkurrenz machen und es ist
eben immer noch so dass nationale
regierungen auf eine eigene
rüstungsindustrie setzen und auf eigene
arbeitsplätze daran hängen ich würde
sagen heute abend das umdenken in europa
hat begonnen aber es wird noch lange
dauern
interessante analyse an vielen dank
das ist also die planung europas für die
zukunft wie die verteidigung der ukraine
ganz aktuell aussieht in einem wald vor
kiew das zeigen jetzt andreas stamm und
oder gar in
kämpfen wollen sie zur not sterben für
kiew die invasoren aufhalten neue
rekruten eine einheit der territorialen
landesverteidigung
training in einem waldstück von kiew
einer der ausbilder der georgier schon
2008 kämpfte der in seiner heimat gegen
russische truppen damals vergeblich
russlands vormarsch auf die hauptstadt
kommen nicht voran festgefahren so
westliche nachrichtendienste eigentlich
gute nachrichten denn diese neulinge
würden versuchen die russen in kiew in
häuserkämpfe zu zwingen mit hohen
verlusten doch ausbilder arthur denkt es
könnte alles andere als eine gute
nachricht sein ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob sie es wirklich schaffen kiew zu
belagern die stadtgrenzen sind sehr
weitläufig gut verteidigt sehr hart die
stadt komplett einzukreisen aber ich
fürchte aus schwäche aus der
verzweiflung heraus weil sie den krieg
verlieren werden sie kiew mit raketen
zerstören so gut sie können aus hass
hass der hass erzeugt auf der strecke
bleibt die menschlichkeit alex einer der
neuen rekruten seit seinen jugendtagen
ein passionierter jäger
was ihnen prädestiniert für seine
aufgabe als scharfschütze
es ist unser mutterland wir müssen es
verteidigen es gibt ja keinen
unterschied zwischen den tieren die ich
sonst geschossen habe und diesen tieren
die gekommen sind um unsere landsleute
zu töten unsere kinder die unsere
gebäude zerstören unser gesamtes leben
russland plane einen abnutzungskrieg den
beschuss kiews aus der ferne weil es für
eine eroberung nicht stark genug sei
vielleicht werden diese rekruten den
feind niemals zu gesicht bekommen doch
sicher ist der hass wird bleiben wir
bleiben noch beim thema krieg gegen die
ukraine 1 du hast weitere nachrichten
dazu ja die us-regierung hat ihre
warnung vor möglichen russischen cyber
attacken gegen die usa erneuert es gebe
hinweise dass russland optionen dafür
prüfen erklärte präsident biden
erforderte amerikanische unternehmen auf
ihre cyber abwehr maßnahmen zu
verbessern ein großteil der kritischen
infrastruktur des landes sei in privatem
besitz
die online-netzwerke facebook und
instagram sind in russland von einem
gericht verboten worden sie seien
extremistisch so die begründung
nach deutschland ab sofort liegt die
verantwortung für den corona schutz am
arbeitsplatz bei den arbeitgebern die
home office pflicht ist ausgelaufen laut
neuer arbeitsschutzverordnung sollen die
arbeitgeber aber zumindest prüfen ob
home office für die sicherheit und
gesundheit nötig ist zu den corinna
zahlen innerhalb von 24 stunden hat das
lka 92 1314 neuinfektionen registriert
64 weniger als vergangenen montag die
sieben tage incidents der neuinfektionen
stieg wieder leicht auf
1.714 die sieben tage instanz der
hospitalisierung also der einweisungen
ins krankenhaus st auf 7,6
vor dem landgericht bad kreuznach in
rheinland pfalz hat der prozess gegen
einen 50 jährigen mann begonnen der im
september einen tankstellenmitarbeiter
im streit über die masken pflicht
erschossen haben soll dem angeklagten
werden mord und unerlaubter waffenbesitz
vorgeworfen er war von dem 20-jährigen
mitarbeiter an dieser tankstelle in
oberstein mehrfach auf die masken
pflicht hingewiesen worden
nach seiner festnahme soll er gesagt
haben er habe sich durch die korona
beschränkungen belastet gefüllt und ein
zeichen setzen wollen
ein flugzeugabsturz in den nachrichten
das heißt nicht automatisch dass fliegen
unsicher wäre fliegen ist im allgemeinen
sehr sicher aber heute hat es ein
tragisches flugzeugunglück gegeben im
süden von china china eastern airlines
flug 5735
132 menschen an bord ein unglücksfall
der viele fragen aufwirft die schnell
geklärt werden müssen im sinne der
flugsicherheit
denn die boeing 737 ist für experten
höchst ungewöhnlich mitten im reiseflug
plötzlich in die tiefe gefallen
christoph distel hat mehr
kreisrund frisst sich das feuer durch
den wald keine spuren einer notlandung
sondern einer katastrophe die die
ermittler bislang ratlos macht denn
ziemlich sicher ist die boeing 737 fast
senkrecht wie ein stein abgestürzt zwei
videos zeigen dass und ein augenzeuge
bestätigt dabei gab es weder rauch noch
feuer die maschine war in einem stück
helfer suchen in dem abgelegenen
waldgebiet nach trümmerteilen und opfern
123 passagiere und 9
besatzungsmitglieder ohne chance der
aufprall habe die boeing komplett
zerstört heißt es über die letzten
momente des flugs weiß man bisher so
viel 8800 meter höhe alles normal als
die maschine plötzlich abrupt ab sagt
drei minuten sturzflug aber mittendrin
das ergaben die flugdaten kurzen moment
als habe jemand vergeblich versucht die
maschine abzufangen der experte ließ das
so das kann in irgendeiner weise
menschliche ursachen haben sei es dass
die piloten nicht mehr handlungsfähig
waren sei es dass an bord versucht hat
irgendwie die piloten auszuschalten oder
auf der anderen seite natürlich probleme
mit dem flugzeug strukturelle probleme
materielle probleme so oder so ordnete
china eastern airlines an alle boeing
737 der fluggesellschaft bleiben vorerst
am boden bis man mehr weiß über ein
unglück das beobachter vor allem so
beschreiben sehr rätselhaft extrem
ungewöhnlich
viele fragen die noch offen sind
was ist besser pest oder cholera
das ist wohl eher eine rhetorische frage
die wahl zwischen pest und cholera will
niemand haben sie ist sprichwörtlich
geworden für eine situation in der es
keinen guten ausweg mehr gibt und die
abwägung aller höchstens noch sein kann
zwischen schlecht und noch schlechter
und damit sind wir bei robert habeck der
gerade auf einer auslandsreise ist die
noch vor ein paar wochen niemand für
möglich gehalten hätte am allerwenigsten
wohl habeck selbst ein grüner energie
minister spricht am persischen golf vor
damit deutschland über den nächsten
winter kommt er redet mit machthabern
deren vorstellungen von menschenrechten
mit unseren nichts zu tun haben um sich
aus der abhängigkeit von einem zu
befreien der einen furchtbaren
angriffskrieg führt kann so ein spagat
gelingen
andreas report berichtet
die inszenierung bedarf noch der ordnung
dann passt an eine gigantische
photovoltaikanlage zur wasserstoff
herstellung davor der grüne deutsche
energieminister perfekter bildtermin
golftour von robert habeck auf der
arabischen halbinsel gestern katar heute
die vereinigten emirate und dabei immer
eins im blick deutschlands
energieversorgung weil wir uns jetzt
anders aufstellen wollen dass er
aufstellen wollen als wir es in der
vergangenheit gemacht haben die
abhängigkeit von russischen fossilen
energien muss beendet werden deshalb
sollen die emirate grünen wasserstoff
liefern katar künftig flüssiggas die
golfregion steht im mittelpunkt von
haseks werben um rohstoffe für die
energiegewinnung länder in denen
menschen sterben weil die autokratischen
regierungen menschenrechte oft mit füßen
treten
was die bürgerlichen politischen rechte
angeht meinungsfreiheit aber auch
diskriminierung von frauen ist ein
problem und natürlich das wissen wir bei
qatar natürlich auch die schweren
ausbeuterische arbeitsverhältnisse auf
den baustellen der wm-stadien leider ist
es gerade im bereich der
rohstoffversorgung so dass viele länder
eben keine lupenreinen demokratien sind
die über sehr viel rohstoffvorkommen
verfügen insofern muss man teilweise den
sauren apfel beißen einen sauren apfel
den die opposition sehr gerne den ampel
parteien zuschiebt geschäfte mit
menschenrechtsverletzer schämt euch
regierung allein in vorbereitung der
fußball-weltmeisterschaft sind auf den
baustellen mindestens 15.000 bau
arbeiterinnen bauarbeiter gestorben die
natürlich aus anderen ländern kommen
sind das ist quasi ein stiller krieg
gegen die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer dort ich glaube man braucht
ein gesamtkonzept und man muss sich
natürlich auch überlegen mit welchen
partnern man zusammenarbeiten möchte und
da ist aus meiner sicht das potenzial
beispielsweise auch mit den usa noch
nicht ausgereizt es bleibt also das
dilemma der bundesregierung geschäfte
mit den demokratie schmuddelkindern
machen zu müssen denn wer gas öl und
wasserstoff sind die produzenten halt
überschaubar experten sehen aber auch
chancen deutsche rechtsstandards und
deutsche hightech produkte könnten die
handelspartner gezwungenermaßen zum
umdenken führen der wirtschaftsminister
hat ja auch zu recht auf das
lieferketten gesetz hingewiesen ich gehe
davon aus dass die deutschen unternehmen
die jetzt verträge machen werden sich an
dieses gesetz halten müssen und dann
natürlich auch prüfen müssen ob in ihren
zulieferern eben die menschenrechte
eingehalten werden nicht nur bei waffen
sind wir ein großer exporteur sondern
eben bei vielen anderen hochwertigen
produkten die gerade in solchen ländern
gefragt sind dass wir da eigentlich dass
ich zumindest hoffe dass wir da wieder
hinkommen eine balance zwischen
wirtschaft und ethik hinzubekommen die
für beide seiten vorteilhaft ist darauf
hofft auch der wirtschaftsminister und
darauf sich nie wieder nur auf einen
rohstoff hauptlieferanten festlegen zu
müssen diese region ist eine
hochleistungs region für die energie
die staaten die ambitioniert sind in der
mission zu unterstützen sowohl was
rechte angeht aber eben auch was den
ausbau einer grün hinter struktur angeht
das kann nur richtig sein putins angriff
auf die ukraine hat deutlich werden
lassen wie abhängig deutschland von
ausländischen rohstoffen ist und robert
habeck auf seiner reise vor augen
geführt dass werte und wirtschaft oft
nur schwer zusammen passen
wir bleiben bei der neuen zusammenarbeit
im energiebereich und der frage nach der
konkreten ausgestaltung
also wer da im einzelnen was liefern
soll frank bethmann was ist da schon
bekannt in abu dhabi wurden insgesamt
vier wasserstoff kooperation sowie eine
forschungszusammenarbeit vereinbart
abschlüsse die entgegen sonstiger
gepflogenheiten in windeseile erzielt
wurden und im kern darauf abzielen eine
wasserstoff lieferkette mit deutschland
aufzubauen gleichzeitig unterschrieb man
abnahmeverträge für erste test
lieferungen und man verständigte sich
auf ein gemeinsames projekt zur
herstellung synthetischen kerosins auf
deutscher seite bei den unterzeichnenden
unternehmen mit dabei unter anderem die
lufthansa siemens energy rwe juniper der
kupferhersteller aurubis und der
hamburger hafen sehr schnell ging es nun
auch weil man offenbar nicht ganz bei
null anfangen musste wie es aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium heißt gab es
bereits eine fortgeschrittene
zusammenarbeit bei wasserstoff projekten
die emirate setzen stark auf
solarenergie wollen global player bei
grünem wasserstoff werden allerdings
wird das alles dauernd man stehe erst am
anfang heißt es aus der branche das
ganze sei ein marathonlauf bethmann
vielen dank die gewerkschaft verdi hat
für morgen die privaten luft
sicherheitskräfte an acht deutschen
flughäfen zu warnstreiks aufgerufen
gestreikt werde an den flughafen an den
flughäfen frankfurt berlin bremen
hamburg hannover stuttgart düsseldorf
und köln bonn hintergrund sind die
tarifverhandlungen die wäre die aktuell
mit dem bundesverband der luft
sicherheitsunternehmen führt sie sollen
am donnerstag fortgesetzt werden
bei einer offiziellen
gedenkveranstaltung im rheinland
pfälzischen kusel haben politik
polizeibeamte und angehörige an die
beiden ende januar getöteten polizisten
erinnert der rheinland-pfälzische
ministerpräsident in drei er sagte die
erschütterung über die tat sei
unverändert groß und versprach auch
konsequentes vorgehen gegen hass gegen
polizeibeamte in dem fall ist ein
38-jähriger tat verdächtigt und sitzt in
untersuchungshaft
das war unsere welt und diesem montag
wir sagen danke für ihr interesse und um
0.20 meldet sich christina von ungern
sternberg mit dem heute-journal update
von uns allen hier im heute-journal
teams an sie einen angenehmen wieder
sinn
[Musik]
guten abend das kräftige hoch peter wird
uns die ganze woche über beschäftigen es
bringt viel sonnenschein mit hohe
temperaturen und das hält die tiefs auf
abstand und wetter gibt's daher über der
iberischen halbinsel
heute nacht wird es kalt im osten da
sinken die temperaturen auf null bis
minus 5 grad im westen bleibt es milder
mit werten von 6 bis 0 grad dazu ist es
meist sternenklar
nur am alpenrand gibt es vielleicht mal
ein paar nebelfelder und einige wolken
an der nordsee die können sich dann
morgen auch über tag x zeigen sonst aber
strahlt die sonne es gibt einen
schwachen wind aus östlichen bis
südöstlichen richtungen und eine hohe
waldbrandgefahr hier im nordosten
deutschlands im süden gibt es eine hohe
sonnenbrandgefahr
bereits nach 30 minuten können sie
ungeschützt bereits einen sonnenbrand
davontragen die höchsttemperaturen
morgen liegen zwischen 12 grad an der
ostsee und 20 grad am niederrhein und so
ähnlich geht es dann auch in den
nächsten tagen weiter der wind
allerdings dreht auf nördliche richtung
es gibt ein paar mehr wolken im norden
und da bleibt es etwas kühler und jetzt
schauen wir noch mal ganz woanders hin
nämlich richtung antarktis da gab es
jetzt einen temperaturrekord mit -17 7
kraft das klingt ja erst mal kalt aber
es ist 30 grad wärmer als man das zu
dieser tageszeit da eigentlich erwarten
könnte guten abend